speaking of number one there's no
stopping Black Panther number one for
the fourth weekend in a row raking in
over 41 million dollars and it's
officially crossed the 1 billion dollar
mark at the worldwide box office by the
way we're going time came in number two
with over 33 million dollars great and
can we go back to Black Panther though
real quick
they're bringing a bit of Wakanda to
Avengers infinity war this is gonna be
massive y'all and only our Brooke
Anderson was exclusively on set let's go
the crossover in this film is I mean
it's remarkable you've got guardians of
the galaxy you've got Black Panther I
definitely geeked out a little when I
was like standing with them all I'm
sorry that's what I came up to you was
like get this man a shoot tell me about
the beer you've got going on right now
yeah crew fat just a lot of like he took
prenatal vitamins actually what do you
think about Thor's sexy new dude that's
working for him isn't it looks good
hideous I can barely keep my eyes on him
how are you guys
the chris's are all here Hemsworth Evans
and Pratt also Robert Downey jr. Tom
Hiddleston Tom Holland Gweneth Chadwick
more than 60 Marvel stars in all the
Wonder Island they have like four lines
in the whole movie there's like the
first day of school when you come back
and then by the end of the shoot you
want to kill everybody et was on set of
Avengers infinity war it took six months
of shooting mostly at Pinewood Studios
in Georgia but you know after ten years
of doing Marvel films together the stars
have become like family now you're not
just a superhero in this world but
you're you're a mommy who's a superhero
yeah when I say you know you want to
come to tsunamis work she's a mom Archie
she loves it a lot of us have kids now
and you and we all started out we were
young and unafraid you know we'll be
alone at the bar alone I'm a generous
poor Chris hey Avengers infinity war
explodes in a theater April 27